look there's no way to sugarcoat it 2020
has been absolutely devastating for most
businesses and i say most businesses
because it's not all of them
some that probably didn't need your help
in the first place are doing even better
than they did before but if we're
talking about the small businesses that
make up your community and you believe
that you can vote with your wallet
your wallet has possibly never had more
power than it does
right now
so when i buy anything a ride takeout a
vacation
i don't often think about where that
money goes but it really matters
what marketplaces i use when i buy goods
and services
i talk to entrepreneur adam jackson
about the inherent problems a lot of
marketplaces have nowadays
could we begin by just i'll just have
you introduce yourself and say what it
is that you do
sure hey i'm adam jackson i'm the
co-founder and ceo of a project called
brain trust braintrust is a global
talent network that connects
people who build software like designers
and developers
with generally fortune 1000 companies
that need them
and have trouble hiring them and
retaining them internally adam i'm
i'm wondering to myself i i'm lucky
enough to still have income
and i want to maximize the amount of
support that i give to
my community in the world when i spend
that income
but i i hear that there's some problems
with the models that a lot of
marketplaces have
have built so we see this play out in
the gig economy is the best example so
the gig economy is about 10 years old
uber was the first company but
it includes lift and doordash and
postmates
uber turned 100 million dollar taxi
market in san francisco into 250 million
dollar ride sharing
so it expanded the market but the other
thing it did
because it's hyper competitive real time
and it incentivizes the lowest you know
the people who
have the lowest rates reduce the
effective minimum wage
so it's an economic disaster right and
why it's because those investors needed
to get returns that
the the taxation on the you know the
fees are
anywhere from ten to thirty percent this
economic problem
of web enabled two two sided
marketplaces has been
sort of a a catastrophe in the building
in the making for
maybe the last 10 15 years and this
coveted lockdown this sort of sort of
restructuring of the economy we've just
witnessed in the last six months
has exacerbated exacerbated it
dramatically
generally you need to raise hundreds of
millions if not billions of dollars in
venture capital
to essentially subsidize one or both
sides of the marketplace
those investors need a return and so
what happens is
the company led by the investors usually
will start taxing the marketplace in the
form of transaction fees
what this does is it ends up creating
divergent
incentives between the users of the
network who make their living
on the marketplace and the operators
and the owners of the marketplace
so for a lot of the spending i do i
don't really have a choice about where
that money goes
utilities rent that kind of thing but i
do have a lot of choice when it comes to
where i eat
and there's no one better to tell us
about dining consciously than
eater.com's jayasaksana
hi jaya hi thank you for having me
so we're here to talk about ethics and
dining
what should i be keeping in mind when i
go out to eat
i think these questions have never been
more prevalent because on one hand
eating indoors or even eating in close
proximity outdoors is very much
considered
a risky behavior in the middle of a
pandemic
but on the other hand you have all these
restaurants and bars who have gotten
no sort of help um
from insurance from landlords from local
and federal governments uh who are
really really relying
on customers to show up
um order takeout to to sit down and
order food
um so yeah it feels like the stakes are
are really
high right now balancing those things
what if i'm ordering
takeout how many of the restaurant
owners you talk to and the restaurant
staff that you talk to
how many are thankful for someone like a
grub hub
and how many are like they are uh eating
our lunch
so to speak i guess for the most part a
lot of restaurants owners see them
as um you know
a bit of an unfortunate necessity
certainly the boom
in places like uh grubhub
ubereats uh postmates any of these
services have allowed
more restaurants than ever to provide
delivery which is you know one one extra
income arm because of all these fees
it really takes a lot of work in order
for that to make it
worth it for that restaurant um and so
many of these services
have things where you know they ask
restaurants to do promotions where they
say
hey if you want to be listed at the top
of these searches you have to pay us
more or you know charge them
for uh you know there's a lot of hidden
fees
and things like that the best thing you
can do honestly
is just talk to the people at the
restaurant
call them ask them you know what would
be
best for you if it's calling you
directly
and placing an order and paying in cash
then do that but if the restaurant says
please
use this app this is how we're doing
takeout and this is what's going to help
us the most
then then do what they say and i think
regardless
you gotta tip well uh 20
20 was the minimum before
this all started and i think right now
um you really gotta go above and beyond
that especially if it's gonna be a
relatively small order
sorry i've just gotta pause the show for
one minute and do some online shopping
ever since i started doing all these
episodes either in here
up on the roof i have to pretty much
order everything online
so i think i'll just go to that online
everything store that everybody knows
about
even if it doesn't support my
community's small businesses there's
really nothing like it for convenience
and price right
henry let me tell you something who are
you i'm mike komarov i'm the founder of
cinch market huh what's that cinch
market started
actually to support brooklyn businesses
to help them we built them a platform to
allow them to team up together
to create the same experience that you
get from amazon
but everything fulfilled by the brooklyn
stores
so brooklyn has a huge inventory of
almost
everything and we don't need anybody to
bring it from
other places but it's not accessible for
the community
you said you go to the everything store
because you want it to be convenient for
you
but how a single store like a toy store
a pet store
can create that everything store so if
you will go today to cinch market.nyc
you will
you will find tons of businesses from
brooklyn
that integrated all their inventory uh
via their ecom platform into one store
and you can go and shop whatever you
need you will find today
more than 30 000 items cinch has a long
way to go if they want to rival amazon
which offers by their estimate hundreds
of millions of products for purchase
how does a local business get onto cinch
market it's very simple
they just need uh to sign when they get
the order
they are responsible for the inventory
we pick all those
orders from the stores and we
sorted back into the boxes
where we bring to the customer it could
be from three four businesses
do these uh do these local stores then
pay a fee to be part of
cinch marketplace they pay nine percent
to
to participate um
we work together with the community to
make sure that we optimize all the costs
to make sure that the model works well
and for
all the different players in the
community do you have plans to
open this platform up to different
communities around the country or
world i suppose what we do in brooklyn
and new york is
is we build the platform and the
playbook for
every city to join that movement i can
already see the comments now
look cinch is brooklyn specific but
let's hope that something like it
spreads to your neck of the woods soon
now beyond spending and consumption
let's say you want to make a difference
with the way you invest
but it's often hard to find companies
who promote values that you agree with
hi henry i'm really excited to share how
you can align your money and your values
through impact investing
hi morgan simon founding partner of the
candide group
what's impact investing impact investing
is addressing the fact that most of us
have no idea where our money spends the
night
right that when we put our money in the
bank we think it maybe goes in the back
somewhere
or we invest in mutual funds and it
winds up feeling extremely
abstract but really it's our money
that's out doing things in the world
and those can be great things like
supporting solar
energy supporting businesses founded and
led by women and people of color
or it can mean that we wind up
supporting private prisons and fossil
fuels and industries that are
fundamentally damaging for people and
for our planet
capitalism has a reputation for
ruthlessness do i sacrifice anything
when i start investing based on values
there's been numerous studies from
harvard business review to deutsche bank
showing that in the long run impact
investors often actually do better
because when we look at things like the
fires that are raging and that are
largely due to climate change
we see that some of the traditional ways
of doing business
actually cause long-term economic harm
and i don't know about you but i don't
plan to retire next quarter
right i plan to retire in 20 or 30 years
and that means that i want to be
thinking about the long-term impact of
my money
and i know that companies that value
diversity that treat their employees
well
that treat the environment well are
ultimately going to be the winners on
the market
so let's say i've got some extra money
to invest where should that go
i think there's three great ways to get
involved with impact investing
the first is simply to know where your
money spends the night for instance
realmoneymoves.org you can get a list
of different community banks in
different states that are really being
thoughtful about supporting their local
communities supporting the environment
and at the same time cash is cash you
know that if it's an fdic insured
institution you shouldn't have to worry
about
your money being safe second is to look
at
retirement funds that often there's
going to be a social choice box and if
there isn't that's something that you
can ask your employer
third is that if you're looking at
individual stocks you can be thinking
about
what is the impact in this community you
can be looking at resources like as you
sew that can tell you
what's the social and environmental
impact of that particular company or
industry
so for instance black lives matter has
an economic justice platform that's been
developed by various activists and
academics
and gives great guidance in terms of how
do we think about the different ways for
instance
that you can have incredible support or
harm for black communities through the
economy
all right morgan thanks so much for
stopping by
[Music]
wow what a realistic looking blimp so
we talked ethical eating spending and
investing
next time you open your wallet give it a
thing